SENPAAAAAAI-
[CRASH]
[Car door opens]
Where's Senpai?
*Gross demonic inhale*
HIIIIII!
*AGGRESSIVE SNIFF*
OOOkay, I'm gonna go on my way now.
Bye Senpai! Have a lovely day at school!
[Distant yell] SENPAI!
The Cooking Club is the first way to win the hearts of all your friends.
And they ARE your friends, no matter how much they scream they're not.
I've got a plate of octopi *Laughs*
They're so cute!
Look at you!
Look at all of you!
OH!
Senpai!
Don't you want my lovely sausages?
It's gonna hurt my feelings-
[Crazed muttering] I might do something crazy-
[Normal tone] -if you don't take my food and put it inside you.
Thank youuu~
[Distant yell] SENPAI!
Who're you?
What the hell?
Alright, you know what?
Girl: Who do you think you are?
'Who do you think you are', BITCH?
I'll smack down with you guys with your stupid wooden sticks!
WOWOWOWOWOW
Girl: Don't even think about it! SHOWOWOWOWOWOWOWU
WOWUWOWIWOWUWIWO
SHOWOWOWOMWOWOMWUW-
[THUNK]
[SMACK]
OW! Why'd you do that?
Why did you do that?
I was trying to do something epic right there, why did you do that?
[Distant yell] SENPAI!
This means I can win a fight with those douchebags outside the school!
I'm gonna show them what for for not accepting my spicy sausage!
*Sigh*
Not eating the hot dogs.
That's what I wanted to say.
Oh!
[Magical whooshing sound]
OHH MY GOD! NO!
AUUH HO!
Ghastly voice: You wish to borrow my power?
Yeah sure, give it to me. *Squeaking*
Ghastly voice: *Chuckling*
*Not-so-evil laughter*
I'm going off to the other world!
Imma kill people!
For FUN!
Oh my god!
Oh, this is amazing!
[Soft screaming]
Hi! Bye!
[More screams]
Hi! Bye! Ohhh!
*Not-quite-sane laughter*
FUC-
Eugh, oh god!
Hey, look at me! It's a puppet show!
HahaHAhaha!
Okay. YOU'RE GONNA LOVE ME!
Repeat after me!
I love Senpai, yes I do! He's for me, not for you!
I LOVE SENPAI, YES I DO! HE'S FOR ME, NOT FOR YOU!
[Tortured screaming]